and if you go too close to that magnet
then it's just going to wipe the tape if
you don't find quantum mechanics
incredibly unsettling just don't
understand we're at six like this and as
a result there are more collisions on
this side
you know there's this very strange thing
about mercury actually they have tails
that do a kind of helical look so while
the blue photons get scattered and then
the yellow and then the green this is a
very hand waving and waving the
description so one simple that's very
important to me is the symbol J and I'll
sprinkle a bit on oh that's probably too
much
ah
oh my gosh this has to be one of the
coolest people I've ever seen I
completely didn't think we were going to
be able to say it like that
if I get them to close they attract oh
that's so strong me
so these are the five basic units I
they're they're cool
I like black holes
Wow did you see that that's about the
highest has ever gone and it's pretty
stable and you shake it about are you
fine with that